الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ونبداها من
تصريحات وزير الدفاع الروسي سويغو الذي
اكد ان المجمع الصناعي العسكري الروسي
بمقدوره توفير وانتاج جميع انواع الاسلحه
التقليديه او عاليه الدقه وفي اجتماع
انعقده بمقر المجموعه المشتركه للقوات
الروسيه شدد شويجو على اهميه تحسين كفاءه
النظام اللوجستيه لتزويد القوات بالاسلحه
والذخائر
تحققت خلال الاسبوع الجاري من استيفاء
مؤسسات المجمع الصناعي العسكري لانتاج
الذخائر التي طلبتها وزاره الدفاع ونظرا
لتوسيع القدرات الانتاجيه وزياده انتاجيه
العماله فقد زاد عدد المنتجات المصنعه من
قبلهم لدعم القوات مرات عده الحديث يدور
عن عده انواع من الاسلحه التقليديه وعاليه
الدقه كل هذا سيسمح لنا بالوفاء بالمهام
التي حددها القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
وفقا لخطه اجراء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه